a lot of times people will do a tactic
and it won't be successful for them and
so then they conclude that the tact
doesn't work and so it would be like
somebody saying i wrote a book and then
no one bought it writing books doesn't
work i rewrote this book five times and
on the fifth time it became the number
one book in marketing and sales on
amazon's and sold over a hundred 000
copies i wrote five versions of that
book each time from scratch again to get
owned and honed and honed and honed more
on the true value that it needed to
provide sometimes the level of effort
that's required is just doing more to
make it better especially if you're
looking at making long form pieces or
making the things that you want to set
your brand on so if you want to give
that piece of free content aware you
want to give that lead magnet that thing
that you want to give away to prospects
that's the thing that you're spending
the most amount of time on because it's
probably the thing that 99 of people are
going to consume and not necessarily
become buyers but 100 of your buyers are
going to be consuming and that's who
you're making it for